[Music]  parking  parallel the what  thing works you know that you're gone  [Music]  I brought you some food okay bye are you  always this unfriendly I am not  unfriendly okay you're like a warm  cuddle  what is that looks like it's yours now  Otto you are not taking over my bed  you think you have to do everything on  your own but no one can we can't stand  watching One idiot try to teach another  how to drive it's less in time  clutch in and break break the car is  stopped I almost hit the car Mr Ryan's a  hybrid my life was black and white she's  always going to be with you  [Music]  my father used to smile like that I'm  not smiling exactly  [Music]  I have a cat  foreign